the Putin progosian power struggle how
it played out in Russia what comes next
the Saudi Arabian Mega project in the
desert the PR Company selling it to the
world
plus Indians have 400 TV news channels
so why are journalists flocking to
YouTube to inform people
hello I'm Richard gisbert and you're at
the listening post where we provide
explanatory journalism about journalism
last weekend as militia forces were
bearing down on Moscow Russians were
temporarily transfixed terrified at the
prospect of a Civil War the world was
watching too as The Afghani pagosian
made his play for power
the leader of the notorious mercenary
group Wagner was a key Ally of Vladimir
Putin but turned critical of the
president and the Russian military's
failings in Ukraine within 24 hours
things suddenly de-escalated fregoian
abandoned his Mutiny and is now exiled
in Belarus
state-controlled media coming out of
Moscow initially did not know what to
make of it all having long lauded
progosian as a war hero they went quiet
for a time but are now back to their
all-out defense of Putin a different
kind of discussion is taking place on
social media however where Russians will
find a diversity of opinion that has
long been absent in their mainstream
news media and analysts have been
deciphering exactly what happened what
is next for Russian politics and the war
in Ukraine
when it comes to information on the
conflict in Ukraine Russia is in an
Undeclared state of Civil War being
fought on Dual fronts there's the
conventional ground favored by the Aging
Russian president where photo ops and
ceremonies are deployed and disseminated
through mainstream channels under the
kremlin's control
and what we saw on Friday and Saturday
was Major figures putting up consistent
message remain calm
and remain calm is not a message that
you use unless there is something to
panic about and guess what the reaction
was on Russian social media anything.com
that is the other informational
Battleground social media primarily
telegram the messaging app where you
have guinea pregosian has more than a
million followers and there are many
other Russians like him there critical
of the war in Ukraine just not in the
way you might think
these are essentially people who do not
oppose the war but they oppose the way
the Russian defense Ministry are waging
this award absolutely
Cadre
and they basically want this world to be
more brutal and more massive than it is
now that's the conflict primarily going
our own telegram channels
the challenge for mainstream media
Outlets that take their orders from the
Kremlin came last Friday when pragosian
put his troops on the road to Moscow
news was breaking far too quickly for
those orders to arrive
Russian news channels were accustomed to
sacralizing progocia and Wagner his
mercenary Army of 25 000 soldiers for
the role they have played in the ground
war in Ukraine yes
they knew that pregosian and Vladimir
Putin go way back that the Kremlin funds
Wagner so when pagosian turned his
forces to the north the propagandists
initially did not know how to cover the
story
and those young Russians on social media
fist bumping pregosian and his troops
contributed to the Russian media's
temporary state of confusion Russia
State media was absolutely caught off
guard by this with certain major Russian
figures commentators are not giving any
comment on it at all Margarita simonyan
the head of uh RT Russia Today made no
comments whatsoever the entire day and
only turned up on Sunday and claimed you
know she'd be on a river cruise on the
Volga
you have to speaks to both how paralyzed
people were and how uncertain they were
of the outcome and and also to the lack
of sort of marching orders from above we
didn't actually see anyone come out and
take preggers inside publicly the really
recognizable
propagandists they kind of held back
um to wait and see how this was going to
play out Putin was initially kind of
missing in action
um until around 10 a.m Moscow time on
Saturday when he came out and gave a
very angry statement
saying that it was an uprising of this
kind that caused Russia to lose World
War one and very quickly after that you
saw sort of Russian State media come
into a narrative that they could use and
now they're very much taking their their
cues from him once again he is trying to
reassert control of the narrative
giving awards to the soldiers that
defended Moscow in a classic putinist
medal ritual kind of ceremony there is
nothing Putin loves more than a ritual
military ceremony coming out telling the
military the country is United we're
behind you so that's what he did he's
reverting to type
The Afghani progosian has been sidelined
if not silenced but there are plenty
more voices on telegram echoing his
criticisms of the Russian generals
Prosecuting this war
early in the fighting military bloggers
started popping up on the messaging app
embedded with Russian troops offering up
close coverage some hawkish views and
eventually stinging critiques of the
Russian military
as long as they do not criticize the
president the Kremlin tolerates their
work and appears to values last month
Putin met with a group of them in some
ways military bloggers are to the
Russian media what progojian's forces
were to the Red Army they supplement the
work of the official institution without
being constrained by the conventional
Rules of Engagement in their case
journalistic ones the main platform for
all pluralistic discussions in Russia is
now Telegram and there is this whole
phenomenon of military bloggers and
quite a few of them Affiliated
specifically with pregosian people you
can call propagandists but they also
important reporters critical about the
way the the war was conducted by the
defense Ministry and they they continue
to be critical after the Mutiny some of
them even doubled down on demanding that
members of the top brass be forced to
resign that this Mutiny happened as a
result of their incompetence their
influence in Russia is very hard to
measure some of them have tens of
thousands of followers some of them have
more than a million and like pretty
origin they've been able to build their
audiences by showing a much kind of
grittier on the ground side of the war
that than you would see on state
television and what's really interesting
actually is the influence they have in
Western media they have access to the
Russian front line which is somewhere
where Western reporters can't go and
they put out videos and images and a lot
of these get picked up by reporters in
the west there's a number of very
popular channels out there on the side
of Greg ocean and of these you know a
number of them were very angry when he
called off his march on Moscow I mean in
terms of you know the number of emoji
reactions you can do on telegram that by
far the top one was uh the clown
reaction these guys were saying we
thought we were fighting for justice and
for the average Russian soldier and we
thought you were going to be the guy to
do it but now we see that you're just a
big of a clown as anyone else oh
taking all of this in with more than a
touch of enjoyment we're Western media
Outlets some of the headlines on
Vladimir Putin's predicament were
downright giddy should they have been
the prospect however unlikely of Putin
being toppled is one thing his possible
replacement however by a progosian or
someone like him calling for everything
in Ukraine from an escalation to
Annihilation panicked Russians looking
for a way out of the conflict before it
gets worse and the reality is that
Vladimir Putin could emerge from this
showdown more powerful than ever
from the Western point of view Putin
looks weaker Putin looks accumulated
it's a bit different if you look at it
from the Russian Vantage Point what's
important for Russians is that what
looked for 24 hours like a civil war
starting in Russia that didn't happen
because the main thing for Russians
supporting Putin is that they don't want
a Civil War and this is what Putin has
been manipulating for for many years now
he is going to manipulate these
sentiments successfully in in future one
of the problems in Russia right now is
that Independent Media has been totally
decimated and what analysts are doing is
they're picking up kind of these
piecemeal
bits of footage and
um trying to extrapolate based on that
right like there was a certain number of
people who did go into downtown rostov
and shake hands with Wagner group
Fighters but at the same time you know
the train station was full people were
trying to get out of town and so a few
guys downtown shaking pregosian's hand
it's hard to sort of extrapolate the
degree of support that shows for a
figure like him um but his telegram
channel has more than a million
subscribers I mean a lot of those are
probably Western journalists wondering
what the hell is going on we don't know
what's going to happen in the coming
weeks and months but I suspect the media
apparatus as it is Will pretty much roll
on unchallenged the media is good at
learning lessons they know the
narratives that work they will learn
from this experience they will figure
out what worked best what persuaded
audiences and if anything similar looks
like it's going to happen in the future
they will roll out Playbook they will
use it and they will keep marching
forward because that is their way
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman has
been hyping his Saudi Mega project in
the desert called neom Tarak NAFA is
here with more on the Kingdom's PR push
Richard neum is a region in Northwest
Saudi Arabia the site of a 500 billion
dollar development project at its heart
a mega City called The Line running 100
miles straight and just 200 meters wide
the idea is to house 9 million people
the line was profiled this week in a
glossy documentary that aired on
Discovery Northwest of Saudi Arabia
untouched almost empty it have mix of
topography mountains valleys Oasis Dunes
beaches Islands corals from skiing till
diving that's the place
that's the Crown Prince and chairman of
Neo Mohammed bin Salman talking up the
Region's natural beauty and a project he
calls a civilizational revolution I have
a friend who moved to his American
friend who moved to Miami in Miami when
he get out from your office immediately
you are next to entertainment culture
sport retails so each date have to be
excitement to finish your work and go
and enjoy it in New York so we are
competing with Miami in that area neom
is designed to be a car free City run
entirely on renewable energy a place
that prioritizes people's well-being but
there is a dystopian feel to some of the
promotional material and Beyond the
feasibility of such a gargantran project
whether it can ever prove sustainable is
the warning from rights groups that
projects like this help rehabilitate the
crown Prince's solid image whitewashing
the way he deals with his critics at
home and abroad which is why the Saudis
have hired the world's largest PR firm
Edelman to handle the messaging neom
recently invited International
photographers to explore the region and
tell their own stories
this place is a dream come true for all
of us
inspiring stuff pretty pictures but with
Muhammad bin Salman Saudi Arabia there
tends to be more than meets the eye
thanks tarek
there is no media landscape anywhere
quite like India's it has almost 400
television news channels broadcasting in
20 languages Indians are also YouTube's
biggest audience and its fastest growing
one the platform has become a vital
source for news digital media startups
gen Z content creators media Savvy
activists from underreported regions are
all doing their thing there and some
well-known Indian journalists have
abandoned Prime Time television slots in
favor of YouTube they have more freedom
online to report on politics and social
issues at least for now the Specter of
censorship is growing under a government
that clamps down on news coverage it
does not like the listening posts
Meenakshi Ravi now on India's YouTube
Boom and why so many people are relying
on it for news despite some of the
misinformation that's thriving there
is a big name in the Indian YouTube
space he isn't based in India he's
actually in Europe with his channel in
which he posts explainers on news
geopolitics history technology is at the
top of a growing list of Indian news and
current affairs Youtubers with more than
11 million subscribers it has a bigger
audience than some established TV news
channels have online
YouTube is where it's at
there were multiple reasons why I
started my YouTube channel one is that
I'm genuinely interested in making
educational videos in a simplified
format which is not available anywhere
else on the internet
problem
but a simple solution my choice of
content was based on what I felt was
lacking in the Indian mainstream media
there was a big empty space there
waiting to be filled in
he was an early adopter there are many
more YouTubers now in India's news
current affairs and entertainment space
there's abhi and new a high octane
couple who started as travel bloggers
and now have nearly 5 million
subscribers watching their newsy videos
then there's sandish Bhatia beneath the
very laid back sometimes scruffy look is
an interviewer who manages to snag
everyone how does this make you feel
like personally I really want like a
genuine answer how does this make you
feel he speaks with high profile
politicians like the leader of India's
biggest opposition party to A-list
actors
there's also a whole raft of journalists
who've checked out of mainstream news
many of them say journalism on India's
Airwaves has become seriously
compromised
in mainstream media I've worked for
almost 15 years there were a few stories
which I really wanted to do while being
there but I could not there were certain
topics certain people they didn't want
to touch I just felt so suffocated
that's the time when I thought that I
should just quit and when I look at
television news debate today I just
thank my stars that thank God I took
that decision mainstream television news
in India is pretty much failing people
when it comes to catering to public
interest if you just look at last month
we had the inauguration of a brand new
Parliament building and there was
wall-to-wall television news coverage
and what the Prime Minister was doing
saying how this moment was a great
moment of Pride for us
foreign
by female Olympic medal winning
wrestlers would accuse the chief of
India's Wrestling Federation of years of
sexual harassment
and it so happens that this man is an MP
from the governing BJP
but there was near Total Blackout on
television about these women and the
protests that was happening
simultaneously at that point you had a
lot of YouTube creators who did
explainers on the issue who highlighted
the protest even we did one video at
news laundry
wrestlers finally decide to march to
Parliament they are roughed up detained
India's Youtube Revolution was propelled
forward by two transformative events
most recently there was a lockdown
during the covet pandemic and four years
before that a mobile data Bonanza in
2016.
Geo will give the power of data to each
Indian to fulfill every dream in
September 2016 one of India's most
prominent industrialists Mukesh Ambani
launched a new mobile service Geo it was
a sensation users were offered four
gigabytes of data free per day within
six months India was the top mobile data
user in the world 1 billion gigabytes of
data per month compared to just 200
million free Geo then in 2020 when
kovitz struck and the country was in
lockdown video streaming got a boost
Netflix Amazon Prime Disney hot star all
saw the benefits and so did YouTube
in the past year two reports one by a
new delhi-based Think Tank the csds and
another by the oxford-based Reuters
Institute have documented a steady
increase in the number of Indians
turning to YouTube for their news
so many that the government of India has
begun to pay attention
how are you
top of the world I'm very excited about
this particular conversation this past
month one of the country's biggest
YouTube and podcast creators ranveer
alabadia filmed a series of interviews
with members of the government
it's one of the first campaigns
organized by New Delhi with a YouTuber a
clear play for a younger audience and
younger voters
when you're speaking the not just me but
like probably the whole Youth of the
country that's listening to this there
is another reason why the government
would be advised to pay attention to
YouTube misinformation
so fake news and hate speech are huge
problems on YouTube you have people
sometimes pretending to be journalists
and these guys do Insane amount of
damage they'll for example go to a
predominantly Muslim area and say that
all these people here aren't Indian they
are illegal refugees they're from
Bangladesh and what we've seen is that
YouTube and any other social media
companies really are very slow at
pulling down these videos often they've
already gone viral before any final
action is taken
now our Fleet we've seen the government
wanting to regulate the digital space
more the question is how much of the
regulation will be genuinely about
reacting to content that is misinforming
people or spreading hate and how much of
it might be politically motivated
monitoring
the very real possibility of political
intimidation or legal threats are a
second order problem for many Indian
YouTubers the first thing most of them
need to work out is how to earn a living
through their content ads the ones you
see before after and sometimes during
videos are a prime Money Maker YouTube
gives creators a sliver of AD money for
each ad View
if your videos are really popular though
then you can go further corporate
sponsorships special subscriber packages
and options for direct donations from
your viewers
I'm not funded by any state governments
I'm not funded by any company it's just
the ads that are being played in between
my videos but people do realize that I
do need some kind of support because you
know you have your staff you have you
have to go and cover elections you have
to spend a lot of money I have certain
subscribers they are paying something
which is equivalent to a Netflix
subscription monthly beautiful
in a media landscape inundated with film
celebrities increasingly commercialized
cricket and shouting matches on TV
masquerading as nuanced discussion the
rise of the Indian current affairs
YouTuber is remarkable
that said something of a record just
more than a month since going online it
is racked up 17 million views it was
about a film that claimed to tell a true
story about women in India's Southern
State of Kerala a film that was widely
critiqued for scaremongering and
islamophobia the whole movie was trying
to project it as some kind of conspiracy
happening in the state of Kerala the
woman from Kerala are constantly
converted and are made to join the Isis
and they're going to join the Isis
[Music]
so all that I said in my video was that
whatever was said in the movie is not
factually accurate this is the real data
and this is the wrongful fact that the
movie has been alleging
propaganda film
later I think a few days after the
release of my video in the Supreme Court
of India actually said that the movie
should now run a disclaimer this is a
fictionalized version of the event and
this is not actually what happened the
fact that so many Indians are taking
their information from YouTube tells you
that there is a serious problem with the
mainstream media in India what the news
channels are showing you there is a big
big thing that is lacking in there and
that's why people are going over to
Alternative sources and trying to get
their info from there
and finally Beijing and the Art of
repressing dissidents far beyond China's
borders earlier this month the Chinese
Embassy in Warsaw tried to block the
opening of an exhibition by a well-known
political cartoonist and human rights
activist Badu Chao a Chinese Diplomat
visited the site in the Polish Capital
threatened its director and said that
the planned exhibition hurts the
feelings of the Chinese people Badu Chao
knows these tactics well beijing's
diplomats in Prague and Rome have
already tried to shut down his shows the
state has also suppressed subversive art
by a husband and wife Duo Lumley lumlong
as well as a Hong Kong cartoonist
valongsir we'll leave you now at the
intersection of Art and politics red
lines that Beijing does not want anyone
to cross we'll see you next time here at
the listening post
[Music]
thank you